ang Krylov quantum diagonalization o KQD para sa maikli ay tumutukoy sa paglutas ng isang matrix value
na problema sa pamamagitan ng pag-project ng matrix sa isang subspace na inihanda sa isang quantum computer na naaayon sa Krylov na pamamaraan isang
makapangyarihang diskarte mula sa klasikal na linear algebra. Sa buong video na ito, tutuklasin natin kung ano ang kapaki-pakinabang ng Krylov na pamamaraan
at kung paano at kailan ito ipapatupad sa mga quantum computer.
Kaya ano ang Krylov na pamamaraan? Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong matrix H na nauugnay sa isang siyentipiko o negosyong pagsisikap na may n na row at n na
column. Interesado tayo sa pinakamababang eigenvalue e 0 at ang katumbas na eigenvector size 0. Tukuyin natin ang isang
paunang vector v na maaaring maudyukan ng istraktura ng h o maaaring ganap na random. Ang Krylov subspace
ng order r na isinusulat natin bilang k r ay nabuo sa pamamagitan ng pagkilos ng h sa paunang
vector r minus isa pang beses na dinadagdag ang resulta ng bawat kasunod na h na pagkilos
sa hanay ng mga spanning vector ibig sabihin ang kr ay ang espasyong spanned ng mga vector v
hv h squared at iba pa. Ang mga vector na ito ay hindi pangkalahatan na orthogonal.
Klasikal, madalas tayong nagsasagawa ng orthogonalization na proseso na katulad ng Graham Schmidt na pamamaraan. Magsisimula ka
sa pamamagitan ng pag-normalize ng paunang vector V at tawagan ang resulta bilang V 0. Pagkatapos para sa susunod na vector HV, ibabawas mo ang kanyang
projection sa V 0 upang gawin ang dalawang vector na orthogonal. Pagkatapos ay i-normalize mo ang resulta. Magpapatuloy ka nang ganito,
kumikilos muli gamit ang H at ginagawang orthogonal ang resulta sa lahat ng naunang idinagdag na vector hanggang sa maitayo mo ang R
orthonormalized na vector na kailangan upang i-span ang iyong R-dimensional na Krylov subspace.
Kapag mayroon ka na ng subspace na ito, ipo-project mo ang iyong matrix dito at dida-diagonalize ang mas maliit na projected na matrix. Mayroong
mga subtlety at extension ngunit iyon ang Krylov na pamamaraan sa pinakasimpleng antas nito.
Upang mas maunawaan kung paano ito gumagana, tingnan natin ang isang trivial na halimbawa. Kung ang H ay ang matrix na ito at ang V ay pinili upang maging ito
na vector, magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng pag-normalize ng V. Upang makabuo ng pangalawang vector sa isang Krylov subspace, kumikilos tayo
nang isang beses gamit ang H sa ating paunang vector at pagkatapos ay ginagawang orthogonal ang resulta sa V 0.
Ang kaunting algebra ay nagbibigay nito para sa V1.
Hindi ito kapaki-pakinabang para sa gayong maliliit na matrix at karaniwang hindi hihinto sa isang Krylov dimension na dalawa. Ngunit kung
ipo-project natin ang H sa ating bagong Krylov space K2, gagawin natin ito gamit ang isang matrix V
na may isang Krylov vector para sa bawat column at ang kanyang transpose conjugate na may mga Krylov vector para sa mga row. Pagkatapos ay
makukuha natin ang matrix na ito.
Ang matrix na ito ay teknikal na may mas mababang dimension kaysa sa ating orihinal. Malinaw na ang pagbabawas na ito ay hindi kapaki-pakinabang sa
sukatang ito. Ang pamamaraang ito ay nilalayong bawasan ang mga matrix na may libu-libong o maging milyun-milyong row at column
sa ilang lamang. Kaya bakit kapaki-pakinabang ang mga Krylov na pamamaraan? Pala ang simpleng prescription na ito
ng pagkilos ng operator ay kadalasang ang pinaka-epektibong paraan upang lapitan ang pinakamababang estado ng value o ground state ng isang matrix
operator. Gawing mas malinaw ito kahit pa iwanan natin ang buong patunay sa kasamang teksto. Nais nating
malutas ang isang problema ng anyo h na kumikilos sa vector x na nagbibigay sa atin ng ilang constant na beses ng vector x. Magsimula tayo sa isang
hula ng ating eigenvector x0. Ito ay isang approximate na solusyon lamang. Mayroon itong error na tatawagin nating e 0. Ngayon nais nating
gumawa ng update ng hulang ito na tatawagin nating x1 na umaasa tayong mapabuti ang ating approximation. Maaari nating ipahayag ito bilang
ang orihinal na x0 kasama ang ilang correction p 0 na hindi pa natutukoy. Maaari
nating ulitin ang prosesong ito nang paulit-ulit na nagdadagdag ng higit at higit pang mga correction vector pi.
Malinaw na nais nating mabawasan ang ating error ngunit hindi lamang ang estado ang ating pinagmamalasakitan. Pinagmamalasakitan din natin ang
pagkilos ng h sa estado na iyon. Kaya ang dami na talagang nais nating bawasan ay ang h norm ng error na ito o ang norm ng
pagkilos ng h sa error na ito.
Ngayon makikita natin na ito ay isang expression na kinabibilangan ng p 0 at maaari tayong magtanong sa ating sarili kung anong mga pagpili ng p ang nagpapababa
ng h norm ng error nang pinaka-epektibo. Mula sa aling espasyo dapat nating piliin ang correction? Sa ilalim ng ilang
kundisyon tulad ng kapag ang h ay symmetric at positive definite, ang pagpili ng unang r na mga correction mula sa loob ng kr ay
pala ay optimal. Sa mas simpleng termino, kailangan natin ng ilang paraan ng paghahanda ng magandang subspace kung saan maaari nating
i-project ang ating Hamiltonian. At sa maraming kaso, ang Krylov subspace ay ang espasyong spanned ng mga vector ng pinaka-
epektibong mga correction sa ating paunang hula.
Para sa isang tunay na patunay, tingnan ang teksto na kasamang video na ito.
Lahat ng aming inilarawan hanggang ngayon ay maaaring gawin nang klasikal. Kaya, paano at kailan gagamit tayo ng quantum computer?
Para sa napakalaking mga matrix, ang Krylov na pamamaraan ay maaaring mangailangan ng mahabang oras ng pag-compute at malaking halaga ng memorya. Ang oras
na kinakailangan para sa matrix na operasyon ng H sa V ay nag-scale ng katulad ng N squared sa pinakamasamang kaso.
At ito ay ginagawa para sa bawat vector na nais natin sa ating subspace. Ang subspace dimension R ay karaniwang hindi isang malaking
bahagi ng N at madalas na nag-scale ng katulad ng log ng N. Kaya ang pagbuo ng lahat ng mga vector ay nag-scale
ng katulad ng order N^2 log N.
Kahit may iba pang mga hakbang tulad ng orthogonalization, ito ang dominant scaling na dapat isaalang-alang.
Ang quantum computing ay nagpapahintulot sa atin na baguhin kung anong mga katangian ng problema ang nagtatakda ng scaling ng oras at mga mapagkukunan
na kailangan. Sa halip na dependency sa laki ng matrix n sa lahat ng dako, makikita natin ang mga bagay tulad ng bilang ng mga shot at
ang bilang ng mga non-commuting Pauli term na bumubuo ng isang Hamiltonian.
Tuklasin natin kung paano ito gumagana.
Alalahanin na ang operator na nagpapalit ng oras ng isang quantum state ay ang exponential ng iH over h bar. At ito ay
napaka-karaniwan lalo na sa quantum computing na i-drop ang h bar mula sa notation.
Isang paraan ng pag-unawa at maging pagsasakatuparan ng naturang exponential na function ng isang operator ay ang tingnan ang kanyang Fourier
series expansion. Pansinin na ang operasyong ito na kumikilos sa ilang paunang vector V ay nagbubunga ng kabuuan ng mga termino
na may tumataas na kapangyarihan ng H na inilapat sa paunang estado. Mukhang maaari na tayong gumawa ng ating Krylov subspace sa pamamagitan ng pagpapalit ng oras
ng ating paunang estado ng hula. At halos totoo iyon. Ang caveat ay nasa
pagsasakatuparan ng time evolution sa isang tunay na quantum computer. Marami sa mga termino sa Hamiltonian ang hindi commute sa isa't
isa. Kaya habang ang ilang simpleng exponential operator tulad ng e sa negative i z ay katumbas ng simpleng
circuit ang mga pangkalahatang Hamiltonian ay hindi at dahil naglalaman sila ng mga non-commuting na termino
hindi natin maaaring simpleng decompose ang exponential sa isang produkto ng mga simpleng isa sa paraang maaari nating gawin sa mga numero. Kaya
hindi ito trivial ngunit ito ay isang maayos na pinag-aralan na proseso sa quantum computing. Nagsasagawa tayo ng time evolution
sa mga quantum computer gamit ang isang proseso na tinatawag na trotterization na sa kanyang sarili ay isang mayamang paksa. Ngunit sa napakataas na antas
sa pamamagitan ng pagsasagawa ng time evolution sa maliliit na hakbang sabihin M na hakbang nililimitahan natin ang mga epekto ng non-commutativity ng
mga termino. Tawagan natin ang Krylov subspace ng order r na nabuo natin sa klasikal na konteksto gamit ang mga kapangyarihan ng h
nang direkta bilang power Krylov subspace kpr.
Ngayon makakabuo tayo ng katulad na espasyo gamit ang unitary time evolution operator u na ibinibigay ng exponential ng iht.
Ito ay ating tatawagin bilang unitary Krylov space kur.
Ang power Krylov subspace kpr na ginagamit natin nang klasikal ay hindi maaaring direktang mabuo sa isang quantum computer dahil ang h ay
hindi isang unitary operator. Ang paggamit ng unitary Krylov subspace ay maaaring ipakita na nagbibigay ng katulad na convergence
na garantiya tulad ng power Krylov subspace.
Partikular, ang ground state error ay nagsasapinid nang mahusay hangga't ang paunang estado V ay may overlap sa
tunay na ground state na hindi exponentially vanishing at hangga't mayroong sapat na agwat sa pagitan ng mga eigen
state. Dito ang mga kapangyarihan ng u ay nagiging iba't ibang time step. Ang k-iyang kapangyarihan ng u ay humahakbang
pasulong sa isang oras k * dt.
Maaari nating i-label ang elemento ng subspace na pinapalipas ang oras para sa kabuuang oras kdt bilang s sub k. Maaari nating i-project ang ating
Hamiltonian H sa unitary Krylov subspace kur. Sa madaling salita,
kinakalkula natin ang bawat matrix element ng h sa kur na basis. Ito ang ating
tatawagin bilang projected na matrix bilang h tilde. Ang mga matrix element ng H tilde ay ibinibigay ng mga expectation value na ito na maaaring
ma-estimate gamit ang quantum computer.
Tandaan na ang H ay maaaring isulat bilang kabuuan ng mga Pauli operator sa iba't ibang qubit at hindi lahat ng Pauli operator
ay maaaring masukat nang sabay-sabay. Maaari nating pag-uri-uriin ang mga Pauli term sa mga grupo ng commuting na termino at sukatin ang lahat ng
mga iyon nang sabay-sabay. Ngunit maaaring kailangan natin ng maraming naturang grupo upang masaklaw ang lahat ng mga termino. Kaya ang bilang ng iba't ibang commuting na grupo kung saan
maaaring mapanghati ang mga termino ang ngcp ay nagiging mahalaga. Kung gumagamit tayo ng unitary Krylov subspace ng dimension r ang
resultang matrix ay magkakaroon ng mga dimension na r * r. Kung ang r ay mas maliit kaysa sa n nagawa na nating
ng kapaki-pakinabang na pag-unlad at karaniwang ang r ay mas mababa sa 100 ibig sabihin madali nating dida-diagonalize ito sa isang klasikal
na computer. Ngunit alalahanin na ang s n at s m ay karaniwang hindi orthogonal. Ito ay
kung minsan ay posibleng i-diagonalize ang isang matrix sa isang non-orthogonal na basis. Ngunit mayroong mga numerikal at pisikal na dahilan
para sa pagbabago muna sa isang orthogonal na basis. Kaya nilulutas natin ang isang generalized eigenvalue problem gamit ang gram matrix s.
Ang mn element ng gram matrix ay ibinibigay ng inner product ng s m sa cn.
Ang parehong mga elemento ng H tilde at S ay kinakalkula gamit ang Hadamard test.
Ang generalized eigenvalue problem ay nagiging ganito.
Tulad ng nabanggit sa itaas, ang dimension ng unitary Krylov subspace R ay exponentially mas maliit kaysa sa ating paunang
matrix dimension N. Kaya ang value problem na ito ay simpleng malulutas nang klasikal.
Upang i-recap, nagsisimula tayo sa isang reference state, pagkatapos ay ino-evolve ito para sa iba't ibang panahon ng oras upang makabuo ng unitary
Krylov subspace. Ipi-project natin ang ating Hamiltonian sa subspace na iyon at tinatatantya rin natin ang mga overlap ng
mga subspace vector. Sa huli, nilulutas natin ang lower dimensional na generalized value problem nang klasikal. Ihambing natin kung ano ang
nagtatakda ng computational cost ng paggamit ng Krylov technique nang klasikal at quantum mechanically. Binalangkas natin ito
nang bahagya para sa klasikal na bersyon at walang perpektong mga analogues sa pagitan ng klasikal at quantum na mga diskarte para sa lahat ng hakbang. Ngunit ang talahanayan na ito ay nag-iipon ng ilang
scaling ng iba't ibang hakbang para sa pagsasaalang-alang. Alalahanin na ang mga Hamiltonian ay karaniwang may mga termino na hindi maaaring masukat nang sabay-sabay dahil hindi sila
commute. Pinag-uuri-uriin natin ang mga termino sa Hamiltonian sa mga grupo ng commuting na Pauli operator na maaaring masukat nang sabay-sabay at maaaring mangailangan tayo ng maraming
naturang grupo upang masaklaw ang lahat ng mga termino na hindi commute. Ang pagbuo ng H tilde sa isang quantum computer ay nangangailangan ng
hiwalay na mga sukat para sa bawat grupo ng commuting na Pauli string sa Hamiltonian. At ang bawat isa sa mga iyon ay nangangailangan ng maraming shot. Kailangan nating gawin ito para sa R
squared na iba't ibang matrix element na katumbas ng R squared na kombinasyon ng iba't ibang time evolution factor. Mayroong
kung minsan ay mga paraan upang mabawasan ito. Ngunit sa magaspang na paggamot na ito, ang oras na kinakailangan para dito ay nag-scale nang halos katulad ng
bilang ng mga shot na beses ang bilang ng mga grupo ng commuting na Pauli term * r^ 2.
Ang mga elemento ng s ay dapat ma-estimate na nag-scale ng katulad ng bilang ng mga shot
na beses ng r cubed. Makikita natin na ang quantum Krylov diagonalization ay maaaring maging kapaki-pakinabang sa mga kaso kung saan ang bilang ng commuting na Pauli
group sa Hamiltonian ay medyo maliit.
Ang scaling dependency na ito ay nagmumungkahi ng ilang application kung saan ang Krylov na pamamaraan ay maaaring maging kapaki-pakinabang at iba pa kung saan ito ay malamang na
hindi. Ang ilang Hamiltonian ay may mataas na kumplikasyon kapag na-map sa mga qubit na kinabibilangan ng maraming non-commuting na Pauli string
na hindi madaling mapanghati sa ilang commuting na grupo.
Ito ay madalas na totoo sa mga problemang quantum chemistry. Halimbawa, ang kumplikasyong ito ay nagtatanghal ng dalawang pangunahing hamon para sa
near-term na mga quantum computer. Una, ang pagtantya ng bawat elemento ng H tilde ay nagiging computationally expensive dahil sa
malaking bilang ng mga termino. Pangalawa, ang kinakailangang mga Trotter circuit ay nagiging masyadong malalim. Ang parehong puntos na ito
ay magiging mas maliit na problema kapag ang mga quantum computer ay umabot sa fault tolerance ngunit dapat isaalang-alang ang mga ito sa near term. Kahit na ang mga sistema na may mas simpleng mapping
kaysa sa mga nasa quantum chemistry ay maaaring makaranas ng parehong hadlang kung ang mga Hamiltonian ay may masyadong maraming non-commuting
na termino. Ang Krylov na pamamaraan ay pinaka-kapaki-pakinabang kung saan maaaring mapanghati ang Hamiltonian sa medyo kaunting commuting na Pauli
group at kung saan ang H ay madaling ipatupad sa mga Trotter circuit. Ang parehong kundisyong ito ay natutupad. Para sa
halimbawa, para sa maraming lattice model na may interes sa pisika, ang KQD ay lalo na kapaki-pakinabang kung napakakaunti ang nalalaman tungkol sa
ground state. Nagmumula ito sa likas na convergence guarantee nito at sa kakayahang mapaglapat nito sa mga senaryo kung saan
ang mga alternatibong pamamaraan ay hindi magagamit dahil sa kakulangan ng kaalaman sa ground state.
Habang ang KQD ay isang makapangyarihang tool, ang mga time-consuming na aspeto ng protocol lalo na ang pagtantya ng bawat
elemento ng projected na Hamiltonian at ang overlap ng mga Krylov state ay kumakatawan sa mga pagkakataon para sa pagpapabuti. Isang
alternatibong diskarte ay kinabibilangan ng pag-approximate ng Krylov state gamit ang mga Trotter circuit pagkatapos ay pag-sample ng
approximate na estado upang makakuha ng projection sa computational basis at pagkatapos ay pag-project ng h sa subspace
na spanned ng mga computational basis state na ito.
Sa mga kaso kung saan ito ay naaangkop, ang metodolohiyang ito na kilala bilang sampling based Krylov quantum diagonalization SKQD
ay posibleng nag-aalok ng makabuluhang pagbabawas sa oras at mga kinakailangan sa mapagkukunan kumpara sa tradisyonal na KQD.
Ang integrasyon ng mga Krylov subspace technique na may mga sampling na pamamaraan sa SKQD ay kumakatawan sa isang kapana-panabik na hangganan sa
mga quantum algorithm.